my david dobrik deep fake tic tac went
absolutely viral
i'm nick anderson and this is how i deep
faked david dobrik
i've been creating special effects
videos for about seven years now
and i used to post them on vine i was
always a huge fan of zack king
and he's the one who inspired me to
start creating my own videos
i'd always heard about deep fake videos
but i never really thought to create my
own and so i said to myself
well it can't be that hard to make them
right turns out i was wrong
this was my first time ever attempting
something like this i was going into
this completely blind
since i had no experience with making
deep fake videos i had to turn to the
internet for help i remember i spent
days searching how to even begin on this
project before i even started
i chose david dobrik as the subject of
the video for a couple of different
reasons
i wanted to choose somebody who tic tac
viewers would instantly recognize
and everybody knows david for a deep
fake to be effective it helps if the two
subjects look slightly similar to each
other
and i think we do so i thought up this
little
mini plot to include in the video so the
video shows me
getting up and seeing this random black
hat on my nightstand
and david's known for wearing his plain
black hats
and the hat ends up being the thing that
transforms me into david from
my clothes to my face it took way longer
than i expected to make this video i
think
the entire process from start to finish
took over a week
i spent a few days researching how to
even create a deep fake video
i spent five days actually running the
program to make it
and then i spent another day editing
everything together into the final cut
the actual process
behind deep faking is pretty in depth
the general idea though
is the program takes the appearance of a
source face
and the position of a destination face
and kind of combines those together
for the program to be accurate it needs
a lot of data from the source face
luckily for me david's face is pretty
easy to find i downloaded a bunch of his
vlogs
and fed all the footage into the program
then the program tries to recreate the
faces
on its own at first the results looked
terrible it was like some sort of
blurry alien distorted face but
each time it tries to match up our faces
it gets a little bit more data
and it becomes a little bit more
accurate i ended up running the program
for over five days and it matched up our
faces 280 thousand times
once i was happy with the result i was
able to just drop it into my video and
edit it all together
what's up guys so ckeek is an amazing
app that helps you buy tickets in
literally the easiest way
possible i've definitely got some mixed
responses on the video
so on one side we've got the people who
thought it was amazing and super cool
and on the other side we've got the
people who said the video made them feel
uncomfortable
which i can understand seeing someone's
face morph into someone else's is
pretty weird out of the 8 500 comments
that the video has
i'd say probably 75 were people just
tagging david on it
overall it was an awesome learning
experience and i had a ton of fun
throughout the entire process
you